thank you
[Music]
all right so um there's something going
on right now at the Japanese
um American National Museum there's a
new exhibit that's open right tell us
about it I love Tokyo I didn't know it's
going on until September and it's
something super super important uh is it
the 30 underwear exhibit
he's gonna like this one
you're gonna feel so weird once the rest
of this is finished
I gotta joke about my peoples I'm
sitting here by association so that's
good 1942 what happened in America you
know in America yeah it's like a Pearl
Harbor well yeah Europe his uncle was
there a year ago yeah in 19 in the plane
though yeah
1942 is where they they took a 120 000
of Japanese American citizens put them
in internment so come from their homes
yep they spread them out across the
country to different camps yeah and then
it wasn't until 1988 where your mama
tried to escape yeah America offered
twenty thousand dollars in reparations
to each they got money though yeah to
each member who survived the camps yeah
but 40 years later yeah but the catch is
that there never was an official list of
who was even in the camps so that was
their way of like oh well here's money
but I mean we don't know who to give it
to so it was hard to get what was due to
you because that's crazy they never kept
that record so it's not until now that
uh there's a guy named Duncan Williams
and he's a director of USC shinso Edo
Center for Japanese culture spent three
years with a dozen researchers and a
hundred volunteers to make the final
official actual list wow of every single
person that was in an internment camp
wow how come white guys are so into our
[__] he's Japanese
he sounded white
he started Asian American [__] he's got
a white last name yeah but yeah Japanese
I'll do it yeah
like that I think he's like half yeah
he's half he's half Japanese okay his
name's Duncan ryuken all right
[Laughter]
all I'm saying is white people are the
Pres preservers of cultures all over the
world dude they be stunning that [__] so
hardcore it's the guilt
they're just into [__] they're like the
most hardcore like yeah they're more
Japanese than Japanese people and [__]
if you go to Japan and then you'll hear
like the best Koto players like a
[__] like red-headed girl or some
[__] I don't know
because she been studying that [__] you
know yeah she was probably more obsessed
with it everyone gets bored of their own
[__] because Japanese people they think
like man Japanese [__] is lame oh you
know what it is though too
hell yeah dude white people are studying
Asian [__] they probably have a chip on
their shoulder so they like I gotta know
this better than like the actual people
I gotta go harder okay that's true yeah
I just think the grass is greener right
like you got a white kid here that's
like I don't want to do cowboy stuff you
know I would do some Samurai stuff and
then they study out there and then some
kid over there is like that's just lame
bro I'm Gonna Learn hip-hop you know
how did they come to America and then
goes bee boy Takashi
all right so that book they they made it
into a big book it's a thousand pages
long and it weighs 25 pounds you can go
to the museum now until September and
you can see the actual book and I guess
like people who are related to the uh
families that are named in the book are
they can like stamp the names to like
show that oh like a certification thing
yeah it's all like their family crest
yeah yeah yeah yeah my uh so my friend's
Grandpa he was a kid during the time he
grew up he has nothing but positive [__]
to say about the internment camp yeah
well because he was a child wait so he
wasn't so for him it was like he was
like
um every day I get to play with my
friends we're together we live together
we get to eat together and then he goes
but after like we all live in different
houses I don't see them every day but he
goes like when you're a kid your
experience you're not worried about oh
what am I gonna do about work you don't
think about that [__] you're just like
I'm with all my friends and we're
camping every day but that's cool
because that's credit to the families
that were in there for allowing their
children to roam like that yeah they're
not put passing on the stress like
they're trying to give them as good of a
life as they can
yeah am I um so so people that had uh
family or or just relatives or just
friends that let them let Japanese folks
stay yeah you didn't have to go to Camp
uh if you were far enough from the West
Coast there was some kind of rule you
had to be away from like these zones
right and then so my aunt she went to
the Midwest where she had some relatives
or something like that she just waited
out the war with their family there but
in the midwest whether it was Missouri
or Kansas or some [__] like that they
didn't leave the house they just stayed
on the Farm property because they said
you don't [__] leave because once you
know you walk the streets they're like
What's this [__] Jack doing over here
you know yeah all right he's [__] Jam
so yeah it's anybody who isn't
unfamiliar so um 1941 when Pearl Harbor
happened America declared all Japanese
anime even if you were a Japanese
American fighting in the war against
Japan you got pulled out and you were
taken put into camp and and so when they
took people and put them in camps what
happened to their homes they just lost
them so
they had to sell [__] they had a very
short period of time to just sell or
what some people did is they had white
friends that were like honorable and
then they just put them under their name
or they took care of the property
so then they're like I'll give it back
to you when you when you move back and
they got their Farm back yeah so some
people were just like I gotta sell
everything in the store so people were
coming in and they're getting dirty
prices one of the conspiracies is um
there were a lot of so you know how like
Vietnamese people do the nail stuff
right and like cambodians do the donuts
Japanese got into the farms and then to
do the Farms they bought a lot of water
rights so one of the conspiracies about
taking Japanese out of that is they own
too many of the aqua Ducks up and down
California that's crazy so uh that like
one of the richest people in California
like next to when Elon was here is a
family that owns all a lot of the water
rights so they're saying like our uh r
as in Japanese Community they were
robbed of their wealth and a lot of the
future dollars because they own so much
of the water in California damn we only
came over and [__] did Nails [__]
oh
sorry dude sorry yeah
I mean it's better than picking grapes
you can do a ton of amount of time we
had the great game on lock you know what
I mean great game
but that makes a lot of sense because I
mean throughout history there's so many
references to controlling water and that
being like the main that's yeah that's
one of the conspiracies of like why they
did the camps because it was like not
just a racist or thing but it was like
yeah also like let's take that [__] out
because we need to control the water
yeah stuff like that but I don't know
you know but I mean imagine how that
looks to get your water control taken
away and then in the 80s oh here's 20K
yeah
um what yeah there are there are people
who owned like Prime real estate all
over Southern California Japanese
families that just had to like figure
out a situation and so imagine like you
own like four homes or whatever and all
of a sudden they're like you got to get
rid of that [__] because if you can't
pay the thing and and handle all your
stuff you can't pay by your phone back
then you know so it's just like boom
it's all gone you just lose it yeah I
heard a lot of interesting [__] from
um like what they discussed about in the
caps and like what like because I was
always asking um like how come there's
hella Japanese people in America that
can't speak any Japanese because I grew
up in the sgv all my Vietnamese Chinese
friends like they were deep like
connected to their culture yeah right so
like in all of my Japanese friends in
the sgv they're like wife well even in
like Hacienda Japanese Church yeah the
service is in English right yeah it's
there's some Japanese but my parents
they grew up there so I'm second
generation or what's called a nisse
right and all of my
um friends grandparents are in the sgv
their grandparents barely spoke Japanese
like they're educated in the states they
sound like old school you know white
folks all that stuff yeah
and I asked them why and they said um
well during the camp there was like a
committee and everyone got together and
they said why did they stick Us in here
and they're like we don't I think they
don't think we're American enough
because they didn't stick the Italians
they didn't stick the Germans they only
stuck Us in here so we're seen as a
foreign threat that's why they think
we're spies that's why they think or we
can't be trusted and then there's guys
that fought for the US there's Japanese
dudes that fall for the U.S in World War
one and they all wore their uniforms
like their decorations and metal their
caps no they when they're getting picked
up by the bus they they stood there like
yeah I'm [__] American but then they
took them threw them in the bus they
sent them all over there and then so uh
at least from like my aunt and what
she's told me their generation had this
kind of
had this agreement of like what we need
to do is just speak English stop
speaking Japanese
yeah you have to you have to send your
children to become uh to join the
military you have to send your children
to become High members of society like
go into politics all this stuff and go
so deep into America that they could not
this will never happen they could never
happen again and that's why you see so
many Japanese politicians and like the
first Asian American politicians are
like uh Japanese-American judges judges
there was a general a U.S general that
was super high ranking because like um
it was just it was just a reaction to
being rounded up and like kind of
treated not American so they're like all
right how do we become more yeah
so crazy when I was growing up I was
like how come all my Chinese friends are
like they got that Pride or like that
they they do the Chinese things yeah you
know what I mean like all we do is like
festivals but nobody speaks it no one
knows it like I was like so confused
but that was the reason why I'm like
damn
that's pretty crazy to hear so yeah the
the the
um heavy thing about all the people that
are going to see this book is uh there
are still people that survived the
internment campsite can look at in that
book today and they're just like like
they collapse when they see it because
it's like this is the first time that
there's proof wow otherwise it's just
like you can say it and then they're
like well where's the records yeah and
there's never been any and so to see it
for the first time to look at your own
name like and you've lived that it's the
very first time so everybody's going
there like it's like a big thing to um
to go see this so if you guys want to
check it out Japanese American National
Museum it's over in Little Tokyo and uh
by downtown L.A uh until September and
across the street there's the Gopher
Broke Memorial uh you guys could check
it out it's the 442nd group
um across the street from the national
uh Museum yeah yeah it's pretty their
stories are pretty nuts
everybody thought he was gonna say
something dumb like must be just boba
time they got really good matcha
happy
birthday
[Music]